كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مدينه طول الكرم شمالي الضفه الغربيه
ودهمت منازل اصحاب محال صرافه واعتقلتهم
وقامت باقتياد الى محالهم واجبرت على
فتحها حيث قاموا بمصادره خزنه حديديه من
احد المحال باضافه الى تسجيلات كاميرات
المراقبه واوراق ومستندات ووثائق قبل ان
تنسحب ليث اذا المشهد تكرر ايضا في تول
الكرم فيما يتعلق باقتحام محلات الصرافه
مصادره اموال وكاميرات ما الذي يروى حول
تفاصيل ما جرى ما المعلومات التي توفرت عن
هذه الممارسات
لديكم نعم اقتحم الاحتلال فجر هذا اليوم
مدينه طول كرم من بوابه 104 عوز غرب
المدينه تحصن الاحتلال وحاصر منطقه وسط
مدينه طول كرم تحديدا دوار ثابت ثابت في
وسط المدينه حيث قام باقتحام عدد من
المحال التجاريه وايضا او تحديدا محلات
الصرافه التي تتواجد في وسط المدينه قام
خلالها بخلع الابواب بعض هذه المحلات اتجه
نحو اصحابها ومنازل اصحاب هذه المحلات قام
باعتقالهم واقتيادهم
الى المحل لفتحه بالقوه بعد ذلك قام
الاحتلال بمصادره ام
قدرت بما يزيد عن 300000 دولار فقط من
محلات مدينه طول كرم حيث اقتحم الاحتلال
عدد من هذه المحلات بعض هذه المحلات قام
بمصادره اموال والبعض الاخر قام بمصادره
اوراق من داخل المحل وتسجيلات
لكاميرات
المراقبه ايضا ضمن سياسه الاحتلال
المتواصله في الضفا ايضا قام الاحتلال ب
مداهمه عماره ايه برج روابي في مدينه طول
كرم وقام بمصادره خزينه او خزنه من داخل
هذا المنزل ايضا يوجد بها اوراق واموال
لتعود لاحد المواطنين واحد اصحاب هذه
المحال ضمن ايضا استمرار الاحتلال في
سياسه محاربه الاقتصاد الفلسطيني
والاعتداءات المتواصله على الفلسطينيين
تحول من مدينه طول كرم الى تيل شمالا حيث
قام باقتحام احد محل الصرافه ايضا في
البلده وقام بمصادره عدد من الاموال
والاوراق التي يعني من داخل المحل والتي
تخص اصحاب
هذه الشركه او هذا المحل وايضا بعد ذلك
جرت مواجهات في بلده زيتا الى الشمال من
المدينه قام خلالها الاحتلال باطلاق النار
صوبه فلسطيني تم نقله الى المستشفى جيش
الاحتلال وعبر الاذاعه الرسميه اعلنت في
بيان لها انها صنفت خمس محلات صرافه في
الضفه الغربيه بانها على قائمه الارهاب
وانها تقوم بدعم المنظمات الارهابيه كما
تدعي حركه حماس وايضا حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي
وايضا الفصائل والتنظيمات
الفلسطينيه وانها صادرت من الضفه الغربيه
اي ما يقارب 10 ملايين شيكل خلال حمله
المداهمات هذه لمدن الضفا الغربيه المحتله
حيث لم تقتصر الاقتحامات فقط على طول كرم
وانما على جنين ونابلس وايضا رام الله
واريحا والخليل شكرا جزيلا لك من طول كرم
مراسل الجزيره ليث
جعار